well it's hard for me to say how
somebody should approach their decision
how to vote I think a lot of times what
people end up doing is kind of a gut
feeling and part of it I think there is
some validity to the whole gut feeling
thing where you can look into someone's
eyes and try to get a sense of their
character and how they carry themselves
and how they answer certain questions
and their consistency over time and and
the messages that they speak of I think
you do get a certain sense for their
character and I think it is important to
elect someone with integrity and with
character but you also want someone who
when they get into office are going to
fight for the things that that you
believe are important and so if a
certain person is in a certain party and
the party line says do this this this
and this and you don't agree with this
this this and this don't elect them even
if you think they're cool even if you
think they're funny even if you think
they're nice or whatever it is if you
don't agree with them on major positions
that are important to you it doesn't
matter how nice they are how cool they
are out how honest they seem if they're
not going to do the things in office
that our priority to you and don't vote
for them and so I think issues need to
be important to you and where there are
similarities among the issues where I
think for instance among the Democrats
Edwards Clinton and Obama there isn't a
huge difference between what each of
them believes on the major issues one
issue that is a big difference I think
is how they felt about Iraq at the
beginning of the war where they've kind
of merged beliefs now but at the
beginning of world one of them was
clearly against it and two of them voted
for it I think that's a major difference
and there's something to think about but
overall I think character and leadership
style is important once you kind of
minimize the differences in their issues
stances and so I think that's something
people should examine and
if you can if you can get a sense of
their judgment and their integrity and
their ability to follow through on what
they say they're going to do vote for
that person as long as you agree with
what they say they're going to do